[Music]
breaking news this Monday night the
prime minister's new measures to
investigate foreign meddling these
threats evolve
and continue to evolve as the RCMP
investigates leaks to the media
the proposed class action lawsuit
against an Ontario group home operator
the trauma former residents say they
endured you have night terrors of the
things that have happened and the
allegations of diverted funds earthquake
survivors suffering in Syria their
uncertain future and the politics still
preventing Aid
plus nothing but deprivation and
oppression we cannot go outside we
cannot thinking about anything that we
want our lives of Afghan women and girls
have deteriorated under the Taliban
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin with breaking news from Ottawa
prime minister Justin Trudeau says he
will take new steps to probe foreign
interference in Canada's Democratic
process including appointing what he
calls an independent special rapporteur
to decide whether it's necessary to call
a public inquiry but he is not
establishing an inquiry himself which is
what opposition parties and others have
been demanding our chief political
correspondent David Aiken is following
all of this for us David what did the
Prime Minister say well you mentioned
that special rapper tour that's really
uh the big news I think today the
special rapporteur is a fancy term for
an eminent Canadian it might be a
retired judge someone with a lot of
experience in National Security but most
notably Trudeau's saying that he will
tell that special rapper tour to advise
him on whether or not to hold a public
inquiry and he will abide by that
individual's recommendation we don't
know who this person might be that's
going to be announced in the future
another thing the Prime Minister
announcing today is the government is
going to take the first steps to
establish a registry for those in Canada
working for foreign governments might be
Canadians working for foreign
governments might be people from other
countries working for foreign
governments the government now says it's
going to maybe establish a registry some
work to be done on that one of the other
things too the Prime Minister announcing
today is he's going to refer this whole
matter of foreign interference to the
National Security and intelligence
intelligence Committee of
parliamentarians that is
nsicop some people call it encicop some
people call it NSI cop but it's that
Committee of parliamentarians that the
Prime Minister thinks should review this
whole matter
when Democratic institutions are under
attack
it is just that it be parliamentarians
elected officials who should be stepping
up to protect those institutions this is
why we create it in a psychop
now the MPS on NSI cop that come from
all parties they have top secret
security clearance so they can review
documents but here's one of the problems
is nsicop does not report to the House
of Commons it reports to the Prime
Minister and so the Prime Minister has
the last sort of right of edit of
anything nsicop says and it's for that
reason and some others that I'm not so
sure that what the PM announced today is
going to fly with the opposition in fact
earlier today we anticipated that the
Prime Minister might be establishing or
referring this whole matter to NSI cop
and we asked both conservative leader
Pierre pauliev and NDP leader jugmeat
saying what they thought about this idea
of NSI cop looking at things and neither
of them like the idea
that's a trick and that's a trap what
they would do is bring opposition MPS or
leaders into a room
give them some information and then
swear them to secrecy so they couldn't
ever speak about it again the process
should be public and that's why I do not
support a committee like the one you'd
refer to the enter cop as an option it's
it's not something that will provide the
transparency in fact all opposition
parties Donna wanna still have a public
inquiry and they have managed through a
variety of procedural processes to set
up a vote in the House of Commons to
have a public inquiry now that vote may
not happen for another couple of weeks
it's a non-binding vote but think about
this the Liberals are certain to lose
this vote in an inquiry and if they do
it's a political pickle for the PM all
right David Aiken and Ottawa thanks with
me is our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson Mercedes a committee a special
repertoire and plans for a foreign
influence transparency registry what do
you make of all this and why is the
prime minister taking this approach
well Donna I think it's a sign that the
political pressure has simply become too
much and the prime minister's office is
realizing that this is something that's
doing very real damage to their brand
and Canadians are concerned they are
seeing the Prime Minister out publicly
and in the past he's been saying look
we've taken lots of action essentially
everything is fine and yet we were
seeing polling and seeing anecdotal
commentary that Canadians don't feel
that way that they are genuinely
concerned about foreign interference
from China as well as other countries
and that pressure left a lot of senior
liberals who I was talking to concerned
that they could be vulnerable on this
file so this is sort of a classic
Trudeau government move we're seeing
they're going to appoint an expert to
make the decision for them it slows down
the political heat that's on them at
this exact moment to say look we're not
the ones who are making this decision
somebody else is we're passing it to
them but it will be an expert decision
uninfluenced by politics and they're
going to hope that slows the leaks down
too which has been one of their other
big problems here Donna they've hoped
that sort of the story would run out of
steam and that that hasn't happened in
fact it's become a higher and higher
Heat score for them and more and more
dangerous for them politically so this
is a chance for them to jump into that
and to say that they are no longer going
to be you know making the decision
themselves they're going to allow
someone else to do it for them really
quickly do we know who that special
repertoire is or when will we find out
we don't know who other than an eminent
Canadian and they will have to choose
someone who they believe is above
reproach and they're going to announce
it shortly and one of that person's
first tasks apparently will be to decide
whether or not there's a Judicial
inquiry or of a public inquiry into this
all right Mercedes Stevenson and Ottawa
thank you
now to a global news exclusive a
for-profit group home operator that was
at the center of a global news
investigation last fall is now facing a
60 million dollar proposed class action
lawsuit the company called hats off is
one of the biggest operators of group
homes in Ontario these are homes for
kids who have been abused neglected
orphaned or have behavioral issues our
investigation revealed former youth who
said they were over medicated and
violently restrained one of them is now
the lead plaintiff in the lawsuit our
chief investigative correspondent
Carolyn Jarvis has the details from
Toronto Carolyn Donna when we spoke with
Jamar Morrison last year he told us that
while living at a hats off group home
things became so dark he tried taking
his own life today he says he's taking
his life back fighting to prove that
what happened to him was wrong it
shouldn't have happened to begin with
Jamar Morrison the lead plaintiff in a
proposed class action against hats off
says he's still traumatized from living
in their group home as a teen you wake
up anxious and exhausted because you
have night terrors of the things that
have happened the screaming the the
yelling the you know kids being thrown
around now he's suing hats off for what
he says he endured those named include
its president Gordon Naylor and his
daughter CEO bronwynn Naylor
the suit which has not been certified as
a class action alleges Jamar and other
kids living at hats off group and Foster
homes were treated in an abusive and
demeaning manner denied their dignity
and basic rights
it says hats off homes were chaotic and
hostile and kids lived in fear the
allegations in the lawsuit have not been
proven in court
Jamar says he was violently restrained
more times than he can count while he
lived there and forced to take Behavior
altering drugs hatsoff responded in
writing saying it will defend against
the lawsuit if it proceeds calling it
baseless unjustified and unproven adding
its homes have passed all Ministry
inspections and any incidents that
happen in residential care are reported
and investigated by the Children's Aid
societies and Ministry
it also previously told global news that
restraints are only used as a last
Intervention when the safety of a child
is at immediate risk and after
de-escalation techniques have failed
it also said it relies on Health Care
Professionals for decisions on
medication and would never direct a
staff to force a resident to take
medication or reprimand them we hope to
send a message to hats off if we are
successful that when you are taking care
of children that their interests have to
come first the lawsuit also alleges the
defendant's diverted funds meant for
kids in their care to real estate
holdings meant to personally enrich
Gordon Naylor
Global News has estimated the value of
real estate owned by the Naylor family
and companies linked to them at 55
million dollars
hatsoff says the only practical way to
open programs for group homes was to
purchase homes through personal debt
and that its private real estate assets
were acquired through multiple private
sources of income that have no relation
to hats off will the minister commit
today to a full investigation into hats
off the Ontario NDP has called for an
investigation into hats off which the
government continues to sidestep as for
Jamar he has a simple message for all
for-profit group home operators
children before money
hatsoff has also served a libel notice
on global news objecting to the series
of stories we reported last fall we
stand by our reporting and maintain it
was accurate and fair
Donna all right Carolyn thanks tomorrow
we begin a two-part series exploring
solutions to Ontario's child welfare
system looking at some organizations
taking a different approach
now to the aftermath of the earthquakes
in turkey and Syria a month later in
signs of the Colossal damage are
everywhere in the earthquake zone
damaged buildings are still being
demolished around 52 000 people are
known to have died in the Quakes and in
Turkey two million people have been
forced to leave the affected areas in
Syria the situation is even worse
survivors are living on the streets
waiting for help that is unlikely to
come Redmond Shannon reports
Iceland family spent five days in the
rubble last month before being rescued
they say they're just happy to be alive
as they recover a few possessions from
the Runes of their home
about two million people in Turkey have
fled the affected areas the Yusef family
originally from Syria moved to this
apartment 700 kilometers from their
damaged home whenever we try to sleep we
dream of the earthquake and bad dreams
it's absolutely horrible especially for
my little brother student Jalal Youssef
says they can stay here for two months
but of no idea what the future holds the
first time when we came to gazante we
were Syrian refugees and now we are
Syrian refugees and we
we came here due to the earthquake and
it's really awful in their homeland of
Syria the situation for those affected
is worse even as late as last night and
there was a a minor Tremor father Tony
o'riordan says thousands are still
sleeping out in the open in Aleppo the
effects of the Civil War have hampered
Aid particularly in opposition areas
the opening of some border crossings has
allowed una deliveries to increase but
there remains little trust between the
Assad regime and the International
Community but what is really frustrating
is the current International position in
the domestic position of the politics of
Syria is impacting so cruelly on on men
women and children now after a month
Their Fear is the world has already
forgotten about them Redmond Shannon
Global News London
in Greece Fury is rising in the
aftermath of the country's worst rail
disaster which killed 57 people many of
them University students
violent clashes erupted between
demonstrators and police on Sunday a
59-year-old station manager has been
charged with negligent homicide and was
jailed late last night pending his trial
the passenger train slammed into a
freight train as they were traveling on
the same track in opposite directions
the wreckage was cleared today the
transport Minister says there will be an
investigation into Decades of
mismanagement of the country's Railway
system
in Ukraine pressure is mounting on
troops clinging to the eastern city of
bakmut as Russian forces close in
Ukraine's top military commanders say
they are holding the lines and want to
keep defending the battered City but it
is nearly encircled speculation is
growing Ukraine has begun a limited
tactical withdrawal there are reports
Ukraine has moved to destroy key bridges
near the city Russia is using intense
artillery and airstrikes to try to
secure its first major victory in more
than six months bakmud is considered a
valuable gateway to the Strategic
donbass region a scare in the air
[Music]
what caused smoke in the cabin on this
flight
practicing patience thousands of
Californians waiting to be rescued from
the snow and why a famous chocolate bar
needs to ditch the mountain it mimics
[Music]
there is no mistaking the Triangular
shape of the Toblerone chocolate bar it
is molded to mimic a famous Swiss
Mountain but now part of the signature
design is being forced to change the
image of the Matterhorn on the package
is disappearing toblerone's parent
company is moving some of its production
out of Switzerland and that violates the
country's so-called swissness law which
requires 100 percent of the raw
materials for milk-based products be
made exclusively in Switzerland
Toblerone will replace the Matterhorn
with a modernized mountain logo by the
end of the year
parts of California will be digging out
for days after Fierce winter storms dump
record amounts of snow trapping some
people inside their homes in the past
two weeks almost four meters of snow has
fallen pushing the snowpack in the
Sierra Nevada mountains to almost double
the amount recorded in a normal year
Jackson prosco reports on the rescues
and what all that snow means for a state
that's battled drought for years
no one was ready for this two weeks of
storms delivering two entire Winters
worth of snow to California's Sierra
Nevada mountains there's nine and ten
foot Burns alongside these roads I don't
see that improving for a month thousands
of residents are effectively trapped oh
my God even if they could dig out of
their homes they wouldn't be able to get
very far people like me are trying to
get out that can and go deliver food and
Hike through six feet of snow to these
homes that can't get out as the days
wear on worry has set in we have
neighbors who are panicking they're
without you know food power
heat medications Rescuers are airlifting
in critical medical supplies like
insulin food is another matter the roof
of this grocery store collapsed under
the weight of all that snow I'm scared
because we've been digging for days some
residents have been told they'll have to
wait for up to a week for Rescue still
all that moisture is a welcome sight in
this parched part of the continent
erasing much of California's
long-running drought in six months the
entire state has gone from extreme or
exceptional drought conditions to a far
better picture where the driest areas
face little to no drought at all the
start of a long road to recovery it
takes more than a single wet year to
really recover a lot of those
groundwater basins that have been
critically overdrafted for so many years
during these last during the strout
digging out is just half the battle two
new atmospheric rivers are expected to
Pummel the same areas in the next 10
days bringing either rain a rapid melt
and the risk of extreme flooding or more
snow to areas that have already had more
than enough
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
some scary moments for passengers on
board a Southwest Airlines flight on
Sunday morning the plane was forced to
make an emergency landing after the
cabin began to fill with smoke
some passengers began to panic and
oxygen masks were deployed the flight
was on route from Havana Cuba to Fort
Lauderdale Florida the airline says
Birds hit one of the engines and the
aircraft's nose shortly after takeoff
the plane turned around and landed
safely in Havana passengers had to use
the emergency slides to get off but no
one was injured
unexplained and unforgivable ahead
reactions to the suspected poisoning of
hundreds of school girls in Iran
[Music]
Iran's supreme leader says poisoning
schoolgirls is unforgivable and should
be punished by death if it's found to be
deliberate
it's the first time Ayatollah Ali how
many has spoken publicly about the
suspected poisoning of hundreds of girls
since November there have been
unexplained illnesses at 50 schools
across the country public anger is
growing over fears hard-line islamist
groups opposed to girls education may be
behind the attacks
a suicide bomber on a motorcycle has
rammed a police truck in Pakistan
killing at least 10 officers police had
been on a routine Patrol when the attack
happened in baluchistan Province the
force of the blast overturned the truck
which caused at least seven injuries it
is the latest in a string of attacks
against security Personnel in Pakistan
the Prime Minister said those
responsible were trying to destabilize
the country it's unclear who is
responsible but separatists in the
region have long been in conflict with
the government
deprived and denied next what the return
of Taliban rule means for Afghan women
the future for girls and women in
Afghanistan once championed by the West
is very much in doubt now the return of
oppressive Taliban rule has brought the
return of draconian interpretations of
Islamic law forcing women and girls back
into the Shadows tonight we speak to one
Afghan woman who used to help others and
is now in desperate need herself Toria
isri and shugofadanish Report
each passing day feels like serving an
indefinite prison sentence for women in
Afghanistan it is
we cannot go outside we cannot thinking
about anything that we want
chocolia atamati helps deliver clean
drinking water to remote areas
she was excited about starting a new
position within the organization
work in a leadership position what
happened
past interview and they end up interview
they say
fund recognition
and it's it's so hard for me
it's only getting harder as time goes on
she shared her story with global news
reporter shagufa Danish shokriya was her
family's main Breadwinner but has not
been able to earn a living since last
December
the Taliban barred women from going to
University and working in Aid agencies
in their escalating attack on women's
rights my father is sick now we don't
have anything in our kitchen room to
prepare for dinner the United Nations
warns extreme poverty and malnutrition
are threatening millions of Afghans
Afghanistan remains to be
largest humanitarian crisis in 2023
despite that growing need there are
fewer Aid workers with women now out of
the equation Charities like care Canada
have had to scale back or suspend
operations which is only adding to the
misery we currently have 900 staff and
about 40 percent of those are women the
needs right now are incredible the
coldest winter in the last 15 years I
mean those needs are not going to go
away but those needs are competing for
Global attention with other conflicts
and catastrophes do you feel forgotten
yes yes yeah I am I'm not in a good
condition the most poor woman in the
world the most sad woman in the world we
know now we are alone
alone and desperate to break free from a
suffocating Crackdown
Taria Israeli Global News Ottawa
tomorrow we'll tell you about the risks
women and girls in Afghanistan are
taking to get an education and how
Canadian Aid agencies are secretly
lending a hand
that is global national for this Monday
I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your Canada
is the Assiniboine River in Winnipeg
Manitoba we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you